you know the nba lost another icon when
hall of famer paul westfall passed away
last week he was a
great player coach and man and i just
want you to listen to this story he told
about
one of his all-time favorite players
we were up in portland and we'd already
clinched
best record in the west and we're down
by one with point something on the clock
i drew up the greatest play i've ever
drawn up
i'm not kidding when it comes to on the
fly
x's and o's westy is is up there with
the greats we had oliver miller who was
the best passer
you could ever find take the ball out at
halfway ahead
charles set a back pick for cedric
zavala's to go to the furlop
we about to win this this is what we're
going to do oliver's going to throw it
off the backboard said go for the lob
do not touch the ball i repeat do not
touch the ball
and i said oliver throw it over his head
i don't want cedric to catch this i
wanted to throw it up by the box
so the ball will bounce off the
backboard the clock doesn't start till
somebody touches it so cedric don't
touch it
and everybody's going to stop when they
see that you don't catch the law they're
going to stop
but charles you keep going you catch the
ball and put it in and we'll win again
we were like okay this is possible let's
go about it and do it
now miller with the ball now miller
awaits look at it under the basket
and
the shot is good the shot is good by
barclay the sons win the game
that's exactly what happened the only
time charles ever ran a playwright
portland stopped playing they just okay
hit the backboard the clock starts and
we wait
they're looking at the table like when's
the buzzer going to ring
charles barkley gets the shot the suns
win the game
and there is disbelief at memorial
coliseum
oh do you believe it charles was so
happy
charles and kevin started running to
each other like it's some deodorant
commercial they're running through the
field and their arms are out
and they're just loving you know they're
just loving life and they're running
they're gonna have this hug
now you would think that kevin's
supposed to jump into charles arms
because
he's a lot smaller and carl's supposed
to catch him well charles
jumped too he's going to jump into
kevin's arms they both jumped
and they cracked knees bad part about it
all the juvenation and celebration
kj comes down the wrong way and gets
hurt
the greatest thing i ever drew up that
worked perfectly
almost cost us the whole season and
that's what
that's how kevin missed games because of
their celebration after that crazy play
and the sons have won the ball game 115
114
how about that
is that a true story it is it's a true
story
he said the dream no no no he was he was
doing it man i missed paul already uh
my thoughts and prayers to send in the
kids just a wonderful person mean a lot
to everybody
to me obviously and to everybody in
phoenix it was just so funny on the play
i remember when he ran to play i was the
only person of the referee who knew the
rule
because if it doesn't touch anything it
doesn't touch anybody and i'm the only
person i'm like
nobody's grabbing that ball and the refs
are just looking
and i just obviously it was a lucky shot
but so i looked i forget who it was it
might have been joey crawford
uh that's a joy that's good nobody knew
the rule
even though the ball did everybody
thought when the ball hit the backboard
the clock started i was the only person
who ruled
it doesn't start to somebody now it's
like i said i hit a lucky shot but
the man that's just a type to me that
was a perfect
no you're the only one who knew the rule
in that game because we would just okay
but
but that to me is a perfect example of
paul westfall yeah
who just humility
makes you laugh i'm going to miss him
i'm glad when i got traded to phoenix he
was my coach
uh but he means a lot to me and the
people in arizona we're gonna miss him i
want to thank tnt for letting me say
that and
i i haven't seen that interview but that
was a perfect
example of him personality yes
personality
my three play players was er wolfe
frazier earl monroe
and paul westfall because paul westfall
was the only person i had saw growing up
that could you
with both hands and he used to shoot he
was the first
ambidextrous person like real in a game
that was taking long floaters left hand
long floaters right here
and then you know is he right here or
lefty and so
i would stay up late and watch the
phoenix
games like that's when tape delay
because the games didn't come on and
they're saying oh no i guarantee there's
other i watch him in the van ardell
brothers
charlie scott yeah i got great connie
hawkins all those guys or like would be
in phoenix
but i tell them one thing funny about
paul when i first got traded to phoenix
he was doing an interview and i was
sitting around late and the guy came to
me and the guy was
talking to me says hey chuck and i just
got my head down just ignoring things
like
hey chuck he said chuck you're not going
to talk to us who are you talking to
he says you he says i says my name is
charles not
chuck he says oh paul called you chuck
and i said
all right from this day forward my name
ain't gonna be so you would never i had
never been called chuck until i got
traded to phoenix and paul had did an
interview when i first got there and
then
the auto reporter i have you in my phone
that's chuck yeah but i'm saying i had
never been
called chuck until paul's paul right now
my first day in phoenix
i've never been called chuck and i says
hey from this forward anybody want to
call me chuck it's all good and every
time i saw him
i told him that story i said hey you
changed my name but everybody calls you
chuck now
but to this day not until i got to
phoenix wow he called me chuck and
i change like hey i'm gonna leave him i
like it you know when you play for the
opposition you don't really get to meet
a lot of
the coaches but every time i saw him you
know he was he was he was nice to me he
used to yell
three seconds like all the other coaches
and uh because you stayed in the lane
five
my condolences go out to his family man
got to do what a man got to do to get
four rings isn't that right kenny
yes sir my condolences goes out to him
and his family
i've heard nothing but wonderful stories
about especially you know when i played
for phoenix for two years so
uh we're gonna miss you coach yeah he
was one of the truly great players in
nba history
he would shoot that beautiful and great
people people but would shoot that 360
jumper
that was so nice paul westfall
oh he had a sweet 360 jumper i need to
see footage of that one
it's out there we'll be right back